Film Courage: Tyler what’s been your experience
looking for an agent or a manager.
I know came from the modeling world in New
York and you had done acting as a child, as
well.
What’s your process like looking for an
agent or a manager?
Tyler Johnson: One thing that a lot of people
I think forget when they’re soliciting representation
is it’s as much an interview for you as
it is for them.
It’s really not a question of who you are
working with or the size of the agency.
I think it has to do with the passion that
your representative has for you and I think
a lot of times as actors we go into these
meetings looking for a certain outcome and
are all too eager to sign on the dotted line
when we hear the things that we want to hear.
When in reality, there are a lot of hard questions
that you have to ask in reverse.
This is sometimes hard to do, as an actor
because there is a lot of in security in this
business.
The one thing I have always been reminded
of (and my Mom does so lovingly to make sure
I stay responsible), but is that the second
you finish your last job, you’re unemployed
and that is the nature of this job.
Sometimes when you’re going for these meetings,
you feel like you’re back on your heels,
as opposed to where you should be, which is
firmly centered.
How can we work together to achieve a mutually
desired result?
So for me, that means I have some questions
when I go in there, too.
But I’ve been lucky enough, especially recently
to come across a great team, a fantastic team
who I really believe in and we’re new to
one another, so I’mvery excited for the
future.
Film Courage: I’ve talked to other actors
and they’ve said that they felt their agent
or manager wasn’t giving them the attention
that they need and these actors understood
this because they had quote “bigger clients”
that they had to deal with.
However, if an actor is feeling that maybe
phone calls aren’t returned, etc., at what
point do they say either I’m being too demanding
or that these signs are red flags and I need
to move on.
Tyler Johnson: Great question….that’s
tough to say.
Because I think that there are two sides to
that.
On one side I think actors rely too heavily
on their managers.
They lean on them, their agents and representation
and they can scapegoat them for the success
they are not having at the moment.
Rather than turn it externally, I feel that
a lot of the work should be turned internally
and you have to ask yourself “Have I done
everything that I could possibly do?”
For me, I noticed (to get into specifics)
years and years as an actor I really wasn’t
aware of the materials that were being pitched
on my behalf, things like Actors Access, LA
Casting, etc. – those certain different
‘houses’ and it wasn’t until recently
that I started checking the materials to make
sure they were up-to-date and low and behold
here are all the old relics of all the old
agents I’ve been with, and here is a misattributed
credit or a missing credits and all these
kinds of things.
For me, before you go blaming others (just
like in life) you’ve got to ask yourself
“Have I done everything?”
For me that really comes down to not just
90%, 95% or even 99%, but am I doing 100%
of what I can possibly do to help my case
and then at that point I turn the blame to
the representation and then make decisions
from there.
But fortunately it hasn’t gotten to that.
Question for the Viewers: What do you think
are the most important steps in finding an
acting agent?